today's the data the Pomfrey was
released I was pretty excited hello and
welcome to I just seen buying a pom
pretty so excited that I actually got up
early to go to Best Buy to check it out
get this line so once I get to Best Buy
I'm expecting with all the hype that
it's going to be the highlighted item of
the day walking to find the bomb free
[Music]
from probe
yep first thing that I find is the palm
Pro 2 hex upon Pro finally I find the
suppose that I phone killer Palm Pre
looks like a little nugget here was my
initial reaction but to be fair I've yet
to touch a working model
his keyboard sucks feels like a crappy
little piece of plastic I'm sad
we've been let down so let's check out
the line here at Best Buy
did you get a pump ray yeah there's
nobody there probably because they
didn't even have a working model that
you could play with so off to the Sprint
store I go it's the best buy sale and
they don't have an actual working model
of the Palm Pre I'm going to spring to
see if they
huh you would figure right well I'm not
this Prince giorno and there is a tiny
little line this line would have been
all the way over there I'm greeted by an
extremely not so friendly Sprint
employee who says yeah I just walked him
through the left because I just wanted
to see the poem before I buy it as well
well I was just at the Best Buy because
I wanted to see an actual working model
before I purchased the phone I'm not
sure why does no one have 100 splay
[Music]
yards because of the inventory of
inventory yes the inventory yeah it's
definitely the inventory now I'm no
marketing genius but let me say sprint I
think you have failed with your campaign
continue running all of the ads you want
but keep up this poor user experience in
store and guess what you almost had
misprint
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh